I'm Anderson Cooper and this is the
wired autocomplete interview ready for
any who is Anderson Cooper I'm glad
that's not the question because that's
very existential who was Anderson Cooper
named after Anderson is a family name
it's my dad's mom's maiden name my
middle name is Hayes H a YS not his A to
Z E which would mean I was named after
Purple Haze which is not the case who
plays Anderson Cooper on Saturday Night
Live there have been very various
permutations of me on tyrant live I
believe Seth Meyers was the first there
was somebody else then who played me and
I didn't love it but I felt bad because
then he heard that I didn't like it and
then recently they did it in like a
party the it a movie like a trailer I
don't know who does it but I'm fine with
it
who's Anderson Cooper's mother oh well
that's an obvious one my mom's glare
Vanderbilt she was this remarkable lady
not exactly the most traditional of moms
I used to view her actually as a space
alien who had crash-landed on this
planet and it was my job to sort of
protect her and teach her how to live in
this world and I pretty much felt that
up until the day she died who does
Anderson Cooper look like Wow hmm okay
honestly the honest answer have you ever
like been in a forest and lifted up a
rock and there's like a newt or a
salamander and it's startled that the
rock has been lifted and then it's
queries away that's what I look like
what does Anderson Cooper like in real
life I guess I'm a little funnier in
real life with my friends and stuff you
know when I do this tour with andhc two
people in the audience often say like oh
I had no idea you were you were funny
and I'm not sure that I am but maybe
they're saying funny to look at what
languages is Anderson Cooper speak I
don't really speak anything I mean I
barely speak English I studied German
for a gazillion years my turkey sneaks
they're good you gotta know I enjoyed
I'm busy enjoyed smacking there are a
few speak German you know how bad my
German is I studied Vietnamese forgot
pretty much all of it Thai and a
Buddhist monastery for a tiny tiny bit
and I studied a year Swahili in college
mean you want a flimsy abaya
I'm a bad student and I forgot it all so
I don't really know speak anything I
wish I did
what Muppet does Anderson Cooper look
like I love this question I don't know I
mean if Grover was you know translucent
I'd say Grover because that would be
cool I think Grover is great
what does Anderson Cooper what was
Anderson Cooper laughing at
I assume this is referencing me laughing
online there's a bunch of videos of me
giggling while I was on the air break
down this the one there probably there's
two one I was laughing at oh we did a
ridiculous about Gerard Depardieu
allegedly drunk on a plane urinating in
a bottle on getting kicked off the plane
it was just full of puns the one that
started it all was I'm glad he didn't
make a debt part - what did Anderson
Cooper drink yeah that I I mean I don't
I I don't really drink alcohol very much
I did on New Year's Eve this last time
and he made me drink a shot every hour
had not had a lot of shots in my life
and reacted in a very strange way doe
does Anderson Cooper Cooper have
eyebrows that is a interesting question
when you have white hair your eyebrows
start to go white yeah it starts to look
like you don't have eyebrows that's what
happens cautionary tale does Anderson
Cooper fly commercial of course yes I
work for basic cable like we come with
package I fly commercial certainly what
I'm paying my own way I can tell you
that much although I will say I have
that experiences when I've gotten on a
plane people start to look at me
nervously
and some people have said to me like is
there something happening where I'm
going cuz I don't know if I should be
going where you're going cuz you don't
go anywhere we're good things happen I
was like well that's I see their point
does Anderson Cooper have bodyguards
that's kind of the question that someone
would put in as they are planning to try
to kill me
both of these are sort of like gradually
getting closer to what is Enderson
Cooper's daily routine and where will he
be at 9:00 p.m. on a weekday night yeah
I have a huge team big security team
just comes with the territory
Cooper have tattoos I love tattoos I'm
obsessed with tattoos ever since I was a
little kid my dad used to draw snake
tattoos my arms cuz I would ask him to
but I can't pull the trigger
I can't I do not I have an idea what I
want I like the idea of like a memento
mori I could go on and I know it's
really parts I know the answers I don't
have tattoos all right does Anderson
Cooper have any pets yes I have a dog
named Lilly she's a welsh springer
spaniel she's super cute my first pet
was a snake named Santa Sam but I
couldn't say Isis so it was Sam when Sam
died I was I was six I was so
heartbroken that my dad had him encased
in lucite and I haven't in my office
still creepy isn't it the ender scooper
wash his jeans yes I do I yeah I do I'm
just gonna say I do because the truth is
I don't but I'm gonna say I do because
people's head seemed to explode if they
hear that I don't the truth is yes I
occasionally wash my jeans I wear a lot
of a PC and a PC they're jeans they
don't recommend that you wash them a lot
I do exactly as I'm told by the pieces
of paper that they're jeans come with
and it seems fun okay cool Anderson
Cooper hmm
how did Anderson Cooper meet Andy Cohen
oh it's a tawdry tale no it's not we had
mutual friends and you know when you
have like straight mutual friends and
they know two gay people so they're like
oh you guys should meet it never works
out you don't need to do that in
frustrated but I had a phone
conversation with him
the phone we're supposed to set up a
blind date and and I knew within 45
seconds I'm talking to him that I would
never ever go on a date with Andy Cohen
and I just imagined him on uh like a
Bluetooth headset walking around his
office just stick you lighting a lot and
then like 45 seconds into the
conversation he asked me he broke my
cardinal rule which is he asked me about
my mom he didn't even ask me about my
mom he'd made a statement of fact your
mom is Gloria Vanderbilt I was like yes
yes she is well interesting Cooper run
for president no no way not even I mean
why does the image Cooper remind me of
dinosaurs
I think cuz I'm old maybe I look
prehistoric or like I've been frozen in
amber for a long time and suddenly had
been revitalized by a scientist on a
strange Island didn't Anderson Cooper
serve in the military no I did not serve
in the military I was very interested in
serving the military and at the time if
you were gay you're not allowed to serve
in the military and were gay and wanted
to you had to lie in order to serve in
the military I yeah I did not
why didn't interest in Cooper leave Star
Wars oh okay I got it I got blowback I
guess it was on cold air show that I had
left the lot one of the last Star Wars I
gotta say I love Star Wars I love Empire
Strikes Back I love I liked his Star
Wars it takes itself seriously if I'm
watching a serious thing I don't want a
charming kid a spunky charming kid who's
got attitude jump in and and help you
know like when Raiders of the Lost Ark
suddenly got a spunky kid in one of them
really I don't think he needs a spunky
kid it's like when I was a kid Saturday
morning cartoons
I think after Star Wars coming up
Saturday morning cartoons often suddenly
had to get like a robotic sidekick
friend I think because they were
influenced by r2d2 and so like the
Wonder Twins suddenly got a spunky
monkey you know to like be their friend
Gleek I don't want a spunky character in
my sci-fi I want Darth Vadar on Obi Wan
I
you know battles and and battles and and
more killings
I don't want humor in in my thing I'm
not even gonna mention
JJB what-what-what Anderson Cooper what
movies Anderson Cooper playing oh god
it's like a walk of shame I've always
resisted being in movies because I
always think it's weird when like an
actual like newscaster pops up in a
movie I was in this movie she called
chappie Hugh Jackman was in it I
recently saw a Jackman I went up and I
said you know you and I were in a movie
together he was oh yeah which one I was
like chappie he looked at me goes I
tried my best
did all I could I was like I know I know
I did too then the other then I was
never again never again I got suckered
in by the Lord Marvel and I did a suit I
would myself in a Superman Batman movie
you know okay we don't need to continue
with that but then my greatest mistake
in life I got offered being Martian and
by then I was so burned I was like I am
never doing a movie again I am the kiss
of death in all these movies it's nobody
else's fault it must just be my fault
I saw Marsden I loved Martian what
happened with Anderson Cooper today good
question
no idea I mean today don't all right but
really honestly it's hour by hour things
can fall apart very quickly whereas
Anderson Cooper eat I go through phases
they eat the same thing every day for
months at a time well for last several
years has been oatmeal and now I've been
drinking Soylent a bunch which I don't
know what are that's going to me and
then I have sushi and but I just I can't
food just I'm a food as a mess like I'm
not interested in it I don't like
thinking about it it's confusing I just
one just a pill every day for food and
that would be fine with me
what does Anderson Cooper reading
actually right now I'm just I'm working
on a books I'm reading a lot of like
historical things what's the last really
oh there's this great book Krishna Dora
that I just read which I highly highly
recommend Krista doors great a little
life is great the song of Achilles is
really great yeah
alright did Anderson Cooper I know the
answer is no didn't I wasn't me Dan
Anderson Cooper always have white hair
ah I was not born this way no with no
disrespect to Lady gaga
I started going white when I was like 21
started as a patch right here then it
gradually just started to spread yeah I
didn't really pay attention to it and
then but by my mid-20s like I've had
full-on salt and pepper and then one day
I looked in a mirror and all the pepper
was gone and now at a certain point I
crossed the rubicon and no one says
prematurely anymore they're just like oh
yeah normally a guy got white hair I
miss being called premature there's a
joke in there somewhere anyway today
miss Cooper played a white Walker yes so
I wasn't actually in Game of Thrones as
a white Walker I did a story on 60
minutes because I am a huge Game of
Thrones fan so when I was doing this
story I said to like the makeup guys
over at Game of Thrones you know that
people call me white Walker and they
offered to make me up as a white Walker
so I went I flew to Kent England to the
studio I and I just sat there was
nothing for me to do my crew was like
okay we're good you know we got that I
was like no no I'm just gonna just gonna
sit here a little little longer and you
know with like my sword over my shoulder
sitting around and having a diet coke
and you know people like Anderson you
got to get out of the white Walker did
interesting Cooper attend the college I
didn't attend college and not only
attend I graduated which I am very happy
about I went to high school in New York
and I went to Yale in New Haven and then
when I graduated I never wanted to go to
school again
okay did Anderson Cooper have a baby he
not that I know of I have not had a baby
Andy Cohen had a baby somebody had
probably googled that it's heard oh he
had a baby I think I confused I love
babies though babies are great although
Andy's baby's a little judgy you know I
mean it's just a little judge I think a
lot of babies are very judgy I love a
nice baby though don't please don't
email me I know people get very upset
but did Anderson Cooper change his name
nope I are they thinking what's curious
to me about this is do they think
Anderson Cooper's a bad name and that I
changed it to something else and they
just haven't heard or did they think it
was something else
and I changed it to Anderson Cooper
because I wanted to sound like a 18th
century law firm probably longer answer
than you anticipate it wasn't it